so let's talk about the media and
politics mixing so New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo was on CNN being
interviewed by his brother Chris Cuomo
talking about this train derailment that
happened on the Metro North in New York
and there might be some level of
conflict of interest there because his
brother is in charge of the Metro North
and does appoint people to jobs there
and Chris Cuomo took some flack for it
and he addressed it also on CNN but I
knew there was no conflict here there's
no question of conflict because he's got
a job to do so do i this was all
fact-based and it's something that
didn't involve him in terms of the
accountability see that changes
everything
if there's something that's been done
wrong in the state level that he
deserves to get hammered he's got an
answer for it
right I wouldn't put myself in a
position because it's going to raise
questions okay so just to be very clear
there actually Governor Cuomo although
he obviously wasn't driving the crane
I'm pretty sure about that
the MTA is a state agency he appoints
its chairman its CEO and five of its 19
board members he also writes the budget
for the MTA so there is some level of
conflicts of interest obviously again
not driving the Train specifically there
is a ton of this in the media right now
where we have politicians related to
and/or married to the people that are
interviewing them or people that are
just in the news talking about them all
the time so this is this is a very small
sample of what's going on so Andrea
Mitchell over at MSNBC she's the wife of
Alan Greenspan who used to run the Fed
Luke Russert who's a big shot at MSNBC
now he's the son of Tim Russert from NBC
News so that's not a direct politics to
media when that's just a media to media
one but it's given him all kinds of
access that no one else would have got
Meghan McCain who everyone says is the
young hip Republican she's the daughter
of John McCain of course Christiane
Amanpour who I think is CNN's chief
foreign policy person she's the wife of
James Rubin who was in Bill Clinton's
cabinet Abbey Huntsman on MSNBC is the
daughter of John Huntsman who's the
former governor of Utah who ran for
president I actually like both of them a
lot but nonetheless and then of course
Chris Cuomo on CNN is the brother
Andrew Cuomo the governor of New York
now and there's just a ton of more
examples of this so before we get into
the specifics of the Cuomo thing how
dangerous is all of this as a general
rule because even if there aren't
specific conflicts of interests
you're never gonna you know question
your brother the way you might question
a complete stranger that's true I mean
you can't fault someone for you know
wanting to get involved in the family
business even though this family
business is a little different I mean
would we be saying this that they were
both cobblers we wouldn't be like you
know so we can't we can't just say that
you know you you have to do something
different than you know your husband or
your father or whatever but but don't
you think a lot of this Cuomo business
would have been cleared up if you would
have just asked a question like what
could you have done differently how are
you gonna fix this in the future because
he said this was all fact base but there
are a lot of questions he could have
asked that were not fact-based
that would have put his brother in the
hot seat and he would have actually
sounded like he was speaking for the
people instead of just speaking as a
family right and actually even as we
tape this down I mean this happened a
couple days before it's still unclear
exactly what happened it sounds like the
guy might have dozed off but they're not
totally sure yet he's very simple to
solve this
I mean sure Chris Cuomo can have his his
spot on new day and actually I like what
Chris Coleman's been doing in general
yeah is that against Chris right it but
it's very simple there's other anchors
at CNN there's other interviewers these
other reporters is anybody they can talk
about this
so the headline turned into home or
interviews Cuomo and I think they knew
that was gonna be what happened and then
they do another segment on that it's a
little bit be cute but right were they
like yeah exactly well this reminds me
of you know just a couple weeks ago
Anderson Cooper in the Philippines the
the government there was upset that
where CNN was shooting and then CNN did
a segment on what the government felt
about Anderson Cooper's reporting and
it's like we keep just making this gross
mix of things but how much should the
public be aware of this kind of stuff so
someone like Andrea Mitchell on MSNBC
who has a daily show her husband is the
former chairman of the Fed that seems
like it might come into play when she's
interviewing people about budgets or
things like that and that's the thing
it can be so simple and maybe again we
revert back to the old man not knowing
how the internet works controversy yeah
people can look this up it's a general
cursory search and like I said when I'm
looking and trying to see if someone is
lying to me I just look up a little bit
of that background and find out what are
the reasons for you to say these things
so you're the one you're the one that
takes the exodus actually give the ship
you're in the business though see that's
the thing most people don't do it it's
great that you do it but what do you
think for the average person you know
even somebody like you know Chelsea
Clinton had a pretty cush gig at NBC
News which I think because she was so
awful finally went away Jenna Bush is a
contributor over there they were both
children of presidents you think that
had something to do with how they got
the job so what should the regular
person do because most people aren't
I don't like slacker cynical but first
of all I don't think most people know
second of all if you if we just took a
cross-section of people on the street
and said how do you feel about this they
would have literally no opinion and I'm
not saying it's because they're stupid
and I'm not saying it's because they're
lazy people just don't care
yeah so I think we're the only ones that
that care about can I even say to may
think oh that's cool exactly Chris
interview and you care about the MTA but
I'd like to see chromatic Cuomo every
Wednesday night or whatever yeah so is
this more of just a sort of baseline
attack on cable news that we just
shouldn't expect more you know it goes
to like the crossfire thing where now
they've issued a new statement where
Newt Gingrich doesn't even have to
disclose when he's interviewing someone
who he raises money for because they
it's so obvious that the show is so slam
they used to have to show a little
something or he'd have to say something
they actually really started on the
chyron they don't like be at Maddox no
policy it's part of it's actually part
of the policy so should we expect it
because what what has become supreme is
getting the ratings again I give the
same the same example Como versus Cuomo
you can do a street fighter put their
heads and do versus round one but so
they can do all that stuff and it's cool
because people I'm gonna watch that have
you on CNN I haven't watched anything on
CNN
and watch this one because it's the
brussels what what they've what they've
generate is we need to find a different
way to get ratings because people aren't
watching us as much anymore
so I'll take this I'm gonna take your
Street Fighter reference and raise it
and say nobody wants to see a tie
between the rows and full disclosure my
voice thrown but I don't remember any of
the other characters but that's the
thing I don't your voice rose
yeah I'm rosin Street Fighter 4 anyway
just we got wait talking about bring it
over here bring so but that's the thing
I think that um I think that when people
tune in to see you know cool vs. cool oh
and then they just see a bunch of guys
like slapping each other on the back and
shaking hands and see how woefully
anti-climactic it is then how did that
help them